presumptive democratic nominee joe biden
is expected to announce in the coming
days who his vice presidential nominee
will be
this says president trump is floating
the idea of postponing the election
with more on both stories now we are
joined by cbs news political
correspondent ed o'keefe in
washington ed let's start with the
potential vp pick
for vice president biden what do we know
about the vetting process right now i
know we've heard there's still a little
more than 10 women
that are involved that's right about
10 11 women depending on how you count
it uh governors
lawmakers former obama administration
officials
most of whom we believe have been asked
to submit sensitive documents about
their personal finances
the history of their family their public
speeches legislation they've
proposed or voted for in the past all of
this leading up to an announcement that
we're told is unlikely
next week but very likely the week after
which would be just the week before
the democratic convention is supposed to
get underway
we also believe that biden will begin
interviewing some of the finalists in a
bid to sort of shrink that list
in the coming days whether he's going to
do that in person
or virtually he wouldn't say and boy oh
boy
we're trying to figure that out and who
who is helping him make this pick
so he's got at least four people who are
officially doing this
his former general counsel from when he
was vice president
his good friend senator chris dodd
former senator chris dodd of connecticut
the los angeles mayor eric garcetti and
congresswoman lisa blunt rochester
from delaware that states only
congresswoman the first african-american
woman elected to congress from the first
state
they have been doing the paperwork
gathering the initial interviews
they're leading teams of volunteer
attorneys who are doing deeper vets
but beyond them he's going to consult
his wife dr jill biden
his sister valerie and about two or
three aides who've been with him since
the 1970s this will be a very close hold
decision you try to talk to people
across the campaign who admit
they don't know much about what's going
on right now what's in his head
that's partly because of the pandemic
and they're literally not around him
but also because they know he keeps
close counsel and
any indication though i feel silly
asking this now after you said that but
i'm going to ask anyway any indication
about what has become the most important
trait or traits to him
in this candidate this is important
because there's been a lot of
conversation about oh this person would
help them when this state or this group
of people likes this person or
she would bring this kind of experience
remember what biden has said
publicly since the start of this he is
looking for someone with whom he can
have
an equally close personal and
professional relationship as he did with
barack obama
and somebody he believes can step into
the job if god forbid something happens
those are the two most critical things
we've spent some time in the last few
days talking to people who've been part
of
the search process for previous
candidates and they emphasize those are
usually the only two things that matter
can this person step into the job and
how close the relationship would they
have with the president
all other things are far less critical
and history shows
picking this person isn't necessarily a
big factor
in who voters ultimately vote for
perhaps the exception of that being
in recent years when john mccain picked
sarah palin
because there was so much concern that
palin perhaps wasn't ready for the job
all right and finally ed not that
anyone's counting but 93 days
until the election um from the polling
you've seen in the reporting you've done
how many people are still making up
their minds
oh very few uh you know only about like
five six percent of voters roughly at
this point it's not who you're going to
vote for but
how you're going to vote uh will you
vote absentee can you vote absentee
or are you willing to stand in line and
and we should repeat again
because we've said it before we will say
it again the president thinks he can
move the election
he cannot do that without congress
acting and lawmakers say they have no
interest in moving the date
that is correct that is a congressional
call ed o'keefe thank you very much